SanDisk imparted just as well as
everybody else
people can party in other ways without
holding up scientific research
last Sunday in the newspapers there was
a story about helium running short
helium is really important for all sorts
of scientific experiments like the Large
Hadron Collider and the reason it's
running short is because everybody is
filling their party balloons and there
isn't enough being left for doing
science it's really strange that one
could run short of helium because it's
the second most abundant element in the
universe they're unimaginable masses of
helium but the problem is that there's
not very much helium on earth because
helium atoms are very light far lighter
than the molecules of air and once
they're in the atmosphere they diffuse
up to the edge of the atmosphere and out
into space and gravity is not strong
enough to keep them here so she's a
balloon helium and helium is very small
gas we use in this case to find leaks in
high pressure and higher vacuum
apparatus because it's very very small
finds the smallest smallest holes the
helium that we have on earth has come
from the decay of radioactive elements
deep in the earth and it's found in some
deposits of natural gas and until
recently helium has been separated from
that natural gas and stockpiled about 20
years ago in the early 1990s america
which had been stockpiling helium since
the 1920s started to sell off the
stockpiles so the price went right down
and it became very cheap to fill
balloons and at the same time people
started making balloons out of this
metallic metallized plastic the sort of
silver balloons that you see everywhere
we told the helium for a long time so
you can sell them in shops in a rubber
balloon the helium comes out so quickly
that nobody wants to buy them and the
result is that we're just wasting this
helium helium is important
scientifically as liquid helium
which boils at 4 degrees absolute that's
minus 269 centigrade and is one of the
best coolants and is particularly
important for cooling so-called
superconducting magnets those that are
used for magnetic resonance imaging
machines that's used in the Large Hadron
colliders and it's also very important
for cooling scientific samples if you
want to do low temperature measurements
as part of my doctorate I used liquid
helium occasionally and I had special
machine that could make the helium in my
experiment and today I went down to the
stores to fetch it haven't used it from
nearly 40 years so what happens here is
that this part is a thermos flask which
you can fill with liquid nitrogen to low
temperature and then there's a fine tube
going down here which takes high
pressure helium and allows it to come
out through nozzles so it comes out of
the nozzle and expands when it expands
through this nozzle it undergoes what is
called joule-thompson cooling and it
cools and liquefies when i use this
equipment it consumed huge amounts of
helium which was really expensive and
once the gas had gone through here it
was just blown out into the atmosphere
and wasted but I did perhaps altogether
half a dozen experiments which were
really important to my work but normally
I used hydrogen which had a higher
temperature but was much cheaper
nowadays at this university people don't
blow off helium when they're using to
cool it but instead we have pipes going
from the labs to a central liquid fire
so we can circulate the helium round and
round so it's not wasted so now I'm
going to take you to have a look at the
liquid fire and see how it's done I've
never been there before so it's really
quite exciting the entrance looks quite
an exciting but just wait
so this is probably the largest thermos
flask you've ever seen it's certainly
the largest one I've seen and this is
where the liquid helium is stored it
holds 3,000 liters of liquid helium
that's nearly $20,000 worth of helium if
you wanted to buy it
so all the labs that use liquid helium
round the campus are connected to this
building by plastic pipes and you can
see them coming in here and each pipe
has a gas meter on it so that you can
measure the amount of gas coming back
now that's very important because the
people doing the experiments get money
for returning the gas and if they didn't
get that money they would just waste it
and once it's been through the meter it
goes into that big balloon and this
balloon is really big you can see
hundreds of cubic feet and that amount
of gas will make really a tiny amount of
liquid enough to fill the volume about
16 bottles of this size about 12 liters
of liquid helium that balloon doesn't
hold nearly enough gas in order to run
the liquefier so there's some
intermediate stages let's go look so
we're now in the compressor room where
there are two compressors here which
compress the gas from the balloon so
that it can be stored more efficiently
and so now once the gas is compressed it
is sent into some storage tanks and
those storage tanks are really quite
impressive though I have to be quite
thin to get there and these are the
tanks and you can see they're huge and
these tanks contain the impure helium
that's come from people's experiments
because they always get a bit of air and
that sort of stuff into the helium not
very much but that would be enough
completely to ruin the liquid fire
because at the very low temperature
the air would freeze and block
everything up then at the second stage
this impure gas goes to the liquefier
which part of which can purify the gas
and then pump it into this tank here
which holds highly purified helium when
this tank is full - not a terribly high
pressure perhaps 11 atmospheres then it
senses its pressure gauges sends a
message to the liquefier that we're
ready to liquefy the gas so the gas when
it leaves the white tank goes into
another compressor which is a clean
compressor which is back in the same
room here the clean helium compressor is
inside this box so you can't see it and
it's meant to make a terrible noise but
fortunately it's not on at the moment
and this box uses more electricity than
any other piece of equipment on the
whole of our University of campus so it
uses an eighth of a megawatt of
electricity when it is running so it is
a very powerful machine and the reason
it needs to is because helium is quite
hard to compress so once the gas has
been compressed highly pure it comes
back here to the liquefier and this
liquefier uses joule-thomson expansion
just like the instrument that I showed
you on the desk in my office and this
can produce 40 litres of liquid helium
each hour so that's quite a serious
amount so it can produce if you like
three balloon words or perhaps even
nearly four balloon words of gas can be
liquefied in an hour and all the liquid
is then stored in this tank and when the
scientists are ready to use the liquid
helium it is transshipped into one of
these smaller doers which is then
taken back to the department's chemistry
the magnetic resonance imaging center or
the physics department and the whole
cycle begins again
the helium goes into the equipment and
it then boils back through the pipes and
into the balloon so when the system is
working really well 95% of the gas is
recycled so now something that never
seen before I'm going to be showing
liquid helium coming out of the tank so
here's the liquid coming out and it's
immediately vaporizing it's really very
cold and if I breathe it in my voice
might go a little higher but we mustn't
waste too much because it will go into
the atmosphere and be lost into outer
space by far the largest assembly of
superconducting magnets in the world is
at the Large Hadron Collider where these
magnets are all round the 27 kilometer
long tunnel and Brady went there a few
weeks ago and he showed me photos of
huge tanks of liquid helium that they
have the Large Hadron Collider when it's
never running out of helium it's just
the price goes up and also there may be
hiccups in supply in this article it
describes some really quite expensive
equipment which because of shortage of
helium isn't running on a number of days
and because they have all the staff and
everything else this is really quite a
waste of money and one wouldn't mind if
the helium was being used for really
sensible reason but if it's just being
used for partying people can party in
other ways without holding up scientific
research and particularly without
endangering the measurements of MRI
scans which are used in hospitals for
all sorts of medical treatments surely
sighs don't want to be seen as party
poopers SanDisk imparted just as well as
everybody else
he and fantastic elements very like my
son but you can fill balloons with
hydrogen but then they explode so if you
smoke so I would suggest that you can
still have a really good time without
helium balloons at a party